ADAM MARTIN: All right,
let's get started.
So I'm starting with
this video here.
What's happening here
is there's this mouse,
and you see there's like
this fiber optic cable going
into its brain.
And the mouse is
asleep right now.
And now the researchers
are shining light
into its brain, a specific
region of the brain,
to activate specific
neurons in order
to test whether they
function in arousal.
And here, you see the
mouse is going to wake up.
There it goes.
It's awake now.
So for today's
lecture, we're going
to work towards understanding
how this experiment works.
And we're going to talk
about how neurons function
and how researchers are able to
control that function in order
to modify behavior--
in this case, the
arousal of this mouse.
OK, so this is going to involve
a particular type of cell
in our body, which
is the neuron.
And neurons are highly
specialized cells
that have a function to
transmit information from one
part of the body to another.
And so neurons are
highly polarized cells,
which you can see here.
On the left of this neuron, you
see this arbor of protrusions,
which are called dendrites.
And then on this side
of the cell body,
you see a single
extension, which
is an axon, and then the
terminus of the axon over here.
And this nerve cell
transmits information
in a single direction.
It will transmit information
from this side to this side.
And these neurons are able to
communicate with each other.
And they communicate at the
ends of the neuron, which
are known as synapses,
which I'll come back to
and talk about later
on in the lecture.
So neurons could be making
synapses on this side
and also making synapses on
this side with other neurons.
So to start to unpack the
function of this neuron--
and I should highlight that
this flow of information
can occur over very
long distances, right?
Your sciatic nerve extends
from the base of your spine
all the way down
into your foot, OK?
So that axon is one
meter in length.
So that's an extremely
long distance
to transmit information
along a single cell.
And so we're going to go from
thinking about how signals are
transmitted in single
cells, and this will
evolve electrical signaling.
Then we'll talk about synapses
and how synapses function
to communicate between neurons.
And this is going
to involve also
sort of understanding how
certain antidepressants,
like Prozac, work.
And then we'll end
by talking about how
researchers did this experiment
to wake up the mouse.
And it all starts with
something that I told you
about at the beginning
of the semester, which
is that the plasma
membrane separates
distinct compartments
the outside of the cell
from the cytoplasm.
And there are distinct
ion concentrations
on either side of this boundary.
So we're starting now talking
about a single neuron cell.
And we're going to talk
about a type of signal
known as an action potential.
Oh, that's right.
So we're going to talk
about an action potential.
And what an action
potential is, is it's
an electrical
signal that travels
the length of the neuron.
So this action potential,
I'll abbreviate this AP.
So when I refer to
AP, I'm not referring
to advanced placement,
but action potential, OK?
So this is an
electrical signal that
travels the length of
the axon and the neuron.
And so in order to have an
electrical signal propagate,
we need some sort of
electrical property
that the cell has
that enables this.
And so I showed you or I told
you earlier in the semester
how sodium ions are concentrated
on the outside of the cell
and potassium ions are
concentrated on the inside.
You see here's the
sodium gradient here,
potassium gradient here.
And now I'm going to tell you
how it is that this happens,
because this is
thermodynamically not favored,
right?
These ions would
prefer, by diffusion,
to be equal concentrations
on both sides of this plasma
membrane, which means that
the cell to shift this
from equilibrium
has to expend energy
to set up this situation.
And so in the plasma membrane
of the cell, there is a protein.
It's an integral
membrane protein
and sits inside the
plasma membrane.
So this here is the
And this integral
membrane protein
is called a sodium
potassium ATPase.
So it's going to have a subunit
that hydrolyzes ATP to ADP.
And the protein uses the
energy of ATP hydrolysis
to pump sodium ions up their
concentration gradient.
So the sodium ions are
going out of the cell.
And this is going
against the flow
that sodium would
normally like to take,
which would be going downstream.
And it pumps potassium ions
into the cytoplasm such
that there's a higher
concentration of potassium
ions in the cytoplasm, OK?
So these neurons expend a huge--
a quarter of their ATP is used
by pumping ions like this, such
that there is gradients of ions
across the plasma membrane.
Now, if one sodium
ion was pumped out
for every potassium
ion pumped in,
there'd be no charge
difference between the exterior
and the cytoplasm.
But what happens in
the plasma membrane
is that in addition to the
sodium potassium ATPase,
there are other channels
that are present.
There are sodium channels.
These are mostly closed,
but there are some potassium
channels that are leaky.
And they're basically leaking
potassium from the cytoplasm
out into the exoplasm, OK?
And if you have positive
charges going out the cell,
then the inside of
the membrane is going
to have a net negative charge.
And the outside of
the membrane is going
to have a net positive charge.
And this charge
across the membrane,
where you have
positive on the outside
and minus on the inside--
I should label this exterior,
and this is cytoplasm.
This voltage difference is
known as a membrane potential.
So this is a membrane potential.
And it's an electrical
potential across the membrane.
If you're an
electrical engineer,
you can think of the plasma
membrane as a capacitor, OK?
So this plasma membrane is
holding this charge difference
across it.
And so there's a voltage
across the membrane.
And in a resting state, the
cell's resting potential
is negative 70 millivolts.
So if the cell is not getting
stimulated by something
like a neurotransmitter,
the resting potential
is negative 70 millivolts,
where the inside is negative
and the outside is positive, OK?
So now I just want to
define some terms that
are going to be
useful for us when we
talk about action potentials.
So when there's this
negative inside potential,
a negative inside potential
is referred to as polarized.
So it's polarized
because there's
a polarity across this membrane,
where one side is positive
and the other side
is negative, OK?
So polarized refers
to if there's
a negative inside potential.
So the resting state of the
side is there's a polarized--
it's polarized.
However, the cell can
lose this polarity
and not have a
charge differential,
or it can flip and be
positive on the inside.
And when that happens, if
there's either zero or positive
inside potential, this is
referred to as depolarized.
Anyone have an idea as
to how the cell would
flip the potential?
What would have to happen
in the plasma membrane
to flip this potential
and depolarize the cell?
Yes, Stephen?
AUDIENCE: You could
open the ion channels.
ADAM MARTIN: So Stephen
suggested opening ion channels.
Which ion channels
would you open?
AUDIENCE: The sodium channels.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
So Stephen suggested
if you open these,
it's going to
depolarize the cell.
Because remember, sodium is
high on the outside, out here.
And so if you open
these channels,
positive ions are
going to flow in.
And that's going to make this
less negative and this less
positive, OK?
So this is the situation here,
where these sodium channels
open, and the sodium
channels-- or the sodium
ions rushing in is going
to create a depolarization,
where you now flip
the potential.
And there's a greater
positive charge
on the inside of
the plasma membrane.
Everyone see how?
Because the sodium ions are
going to just go downstream.
They're higher
concentration out here.
So just by opening
these channels,
the cell doesn't have to
do any work to do this.
Sodium is just going to
flow down its gradient
into the cytoplasm.
So what an action
potential is, is it's
a transient depolarization
of the nerve cell.
So the Action Potential, or AP,
is a transient depolarization
of the neuron, which
means it doesn't just
depolarize and stay depolarized,
but it depolarizes and then
restores itself back to
the resting polarity.
And so what you see when
you measure the voltage
across the plasma
membrane in a neuron,
you see that it can
spike and depolarize,
but then it's rapidly restored
to its resting state, OK?
So it's a transient process.
When we think about the neuron
at higher resolution, what
you're going to see is
not only is it transient,
but it's also a traveling
wave that propagates along
the entire length of the cell.
So this is also
a traveling wave.
And one thing that you can
notice about these neurons,
or the action potentials
here, is that they all
depolarize to the same extent.
So they all depolarize to
this positive 50 millivolts.
And so this illustrates
a key property
of neurons, in that the
level of activity of a neuron
is not determined by the size
of this action potential.
This action potential is
an all-or-nothing event.
It either happens or it doesn't.
And when it happens, it
depolarizes to the same level.
So the action potential
is all or nothing.
You can think of it
as a binary signal.
And therefore, the
way that neurons
encode sort of the
magnitude of activation
is not through the
level of depolarization
of a single action
potential, but it
is able to distinguish between
different frequencies of action
potentials that are
propagating along the neuron.
So signal strength,
in this case,
is related to the frequency
of action potentials firing.
So now we're going
to unpack how it
is a nerve cell fires
an action potential
and how it propagates along
the entire cell length, right?
In the case of
the sciatic nerve,
this has to happen across
an entire meter, OK?
That's a very long
distance to propagate
this change in electrical
signal, at least for a cell.
And so we're going to
talk about the mechanism.
And I'm going to start at the
beginning, when this action
potential initiates.
So we'll start at the initiation
of the action potential.
So how is it that
this nerve cell
is told to start depolarizing
at the dendrites?
Because there's going to
be another neuron here,
which is going to communicate
to this neuron over here
to tell it to
start depolarizing.
It does this at the location
known as the synapse, which
is basically sort of the
connection between the two
neurons.
And the way this
process is initiated
is similar to the
type of signaling
that you saw in the past
few lectures, where you have
a ligand and a receptor, OK?
In this case, the
ligand is going
to be what's known as a
neurotransmitter, which
is a small molecule.
And I'll show you some later on.
And the receptor is going
to be a receptor that
binds to this ligand.
But in this case, rather
than being something
like a G protein coupled
receptor or a receptor tyrosine
kinase, the receptor is going
to be an ion channel, OK?
So the receptor is going
to be an ion channel.
And so you see one
example in the slide
up here, where
here's a receptor.
And these receptors are what
are known as ligand-gated ion
channels.
In this case, it's
a sodium channel.
So it's going to be--
whether or not it's open depends
on the presence of the ligand.
So if we take a
neurotransmitter like serotonin,
if it's not bound
to the receptor,
the receptor is closed.
But if serotonin
binds to the receptor,
it opens up the channel,
which can selectively
let in a type of ion--
in this case, sodium.
In this case, this is
an activating channel,
because letting
in sodium is going
to depolarize the cell, OK?
So this ligand receptor
binding uses a ligand-gated--
there's a ligand-gated
sodium channel.
And it's this ligand-gated
sodium channel which
starts the depolarization.
So that's how you sort of knock
over the first domino, right?
But then there has
to be some mechanism
to propagate this along the
length of a very long cell.
And so I'll tell you this
involves a different type
of sort of signaling
mechanism from what you're
used to thinking about, because
this involves a different type
of an ion channel.
And it's called a voltage gated.
And I'll abbreviate
voltage gated just VG.
And in this case, it
will be a sodium channel.
So what's a voltage-gated
sodium channel?
This is a voltage-gated
sodium channel here.
And you can see, in the
resting state of the cell,
this channel is closed.
And it's closed because
of this red rod structure
that's positively charged.
That's a positively
charged alpha helix
that is a part of
this protein and is
embedded in the membrane.
But this alpha helix
is positioned down
towards the cytoplasm, because
it's positively charged.
And the cytosolic face
of the plasma membrane
is negatively charged, OK?
And the confirmation
of this protein
then depends on the charge
across this membrane.
Because when there
is depolarization,
that shifts the position of this
alpha helix, such that now it
shifts up towards the exterior
face of the plasma membrane.
And that opens the channel,
which lets sodium ions rush in,
OK?
Again, sodium ions here, they're
always rushing downstream.
They're concentration gradient.
So in this case, whether or not
this channel is open or closed
depends not on the
presence of a ligand,
but on the membrane potential
across the plasma membrane.
So these voltage-gated
sodium channels,
they're opened by
depolarization.
And then the question
becomes, if you
open these channels at the
very end of the neuron,
how do you get it such that
this electrical signal moves
unidirectionally
along the neuron?
So what leads to
unidirectionality?
Who's been to a
sporting event lately?
OK, good.
You guys know the wave?
So we're going to do the wave.
Once you to stand up,
you're going to be tired,
and you're going to have
to sit down for a while.
I'm going to be a ligand--
I'm a ligand-gated
sodium channel,
so I'm going to
start things off, OK?
You ready?
All right, here we go.
OK, that's basically
an action potential.
So the way that this
was unidirectional
is once you stood up and did
the wave, you then sat down,
and you stopped doing anything.
And so these voltage-gated
sodium channels
have a similar property.
If we look at the
next step in this,
the sodium channel is
opened by depolarization.
And you see there's this ball
of chain segment of the protein.
You see that yellow ball?
Once the sodium channel opens,
after about a millisecond,
that ball sticks in the
channel pore and blocks it, OK?
So these sodium channels
open to let in sodium ions,
but then they're
immediately inactivated
after about a millisecond, OK?
And so that enables
unidirectionality.
So this is what I'll call
voltage-gated sodium channel
inactivation.
And how this
promotes a traveling
wave of depolarization is
that if we consider an action
potential moving along this
axon from left to right
and if the sodium
channels in the green zone
are currently open,
it came from the left,
which means that all
the sodium channels
to the left of this green zone
are going to be inactivated.
So because they're
inactivated here,
there won't be
further depolarization
going to the left,
but depolarization
will have to move to the right.
And you basically get
this traveling wave.
And it goes one
direction, because if it
came from somewhere, which it
always does, then where it just
was coming from,
all those sodium
channels, the voltage-gated
sodium channels
are going to be closed.
So this allows it to move
in a single direction
along the neuron.
Also, once the action potential
gets to the end of the neuron,
it doesn't reflect back the
other way in the neuron.
This can only go one direction.
So this provides
unidirectionality.
So it's this inactive
or refractory period
of the voltage-gated
sodium channel
which prevents the
action potential
from moving backwards.
Now, if you look at these
action potentials in the cell,
you see that they happen,
but you don't just
depolarize and stay depolarized.
The cell body depolarizes and
then repolarizes very rapidly.
So there's an oscillation.
So there has to be some way to
terminate the action potential.
So there's a termination or
repolarization of the cell.
So there has to be a
way for this nerve cell
to rapidly restore
membrane potential.
And I want you to think for
just a couple of seconds
about what type of
channel might you open
to re-establish this polarity.
What ion do you need to flow
from where to where in order
to get a net negative
charge on the inside?
Udo?
AUDIENCE: You need to
move the sodium ions
from the inside to the outside.
ADAM MARTIN: OK, you could
pump the sodium ions out,
and that's totally accurate.
So that's going to
require moving sodium ions
up a concentration gradient,
which is going to take energy
and is going to be slow.
So is there another option we
could take advantage of here
to repolarize?
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: Move the
potassium ions.
ADAM MARTIN: So
Rachel has suggested
to moving the potassium
ions to the outside, which
is how this is done.
So remember, potassium is
high in the cytoplasmic,
low on the exoplasm.
And therefore, if you have
a voltage-gated potassium
channel, that's going to cause
a rush of positive ions out
of the cell.
And that will be able to restore
the net negative potential
on the inside of the cell.
So this termination
or repolarization
is the result of the opening
of voltage gated, in this case,
not sodium channels,
but potassium channels.
When do you think these
have to open relative
to the sodium channel?
Should they open right
with the sodium channel?
Carmen's shaking her head no.
Do you want to
explain your logic?
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, they
both carry the same charge,
so they wind up getting out
at the same time [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
So what Carmen said is if
they open simultaneously,
you have sodium flowing in.
You have potassium flowing out.
And that's not going to
necessarily change the charge.
So when would these have to open
relative to sodium channels?
Yeah, Carmen?
AUDIENCE: When it reaches
that potential [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: So after
it's depolarized, yeah.
So this has to be delayed
relative to the sodium
channels, OK?
So this has to be
delayed relative
to the voltage-gated
sodium channels.
Because if you're thinking
about this traveling
wave of depolarization,
the depolarization
is going to be high where
the sodium channels are only
entering.
And then following
that, you would
have potassium ions
getting pumped out
and basically
repolarizing the cell.
Everyone see how you sort
of get depolarization
with sodium rushing in,
and then after that, you
repolarize with the potassium
getting pumped out, right?
So here, you have a spike,
and you complete the cycle.
It can even get hyperpolarized,
where it gets even more
negative than it normally does.
And then it eventually gets
back to this resting potential
of around negative 60 or
negative 70 millivolts.
OK, so this has to happen fast.
And I want to tell you about one
process or property of neurons
and another helpful
cell that enables
this to go extremely fast.
And that is that there are
these glial cells in your body
and your brain that
wrap around the axons
of the neurons and basically
function like electrical tape
for neurons, OK?
So they are these--
there's electrical
insulation around the axons
of these neurons.
And this is provided by
another specialized cell
type called a glial cell.
So this is by a glial cell.
And here are two
examples of glial cells.
There are
oligodendrocytes-- and you
can see how the cell
is extending processes
that wrap around the axons
of these two neurons.
Here's a Schwann
cell over here, which
again, wraps around the axon.
And these cells basically form
what's called a myelin sheath.
So they form a myelin
sheath around the axons.
And that insulates the
plasma membrane of the axon
such that--
so here is an axon.
You have glial cells
that are wrapped around,
and it sort of forms
like beads on a string.
And so there are these gaps
between the myelin sheath
that are known as
the nodes of Ranvier.
So there are these
nodes of Ranvier, which
are gaps in the myelin sheath.
And these nodes perform
an important function
for the neuron, because
where the axon is wrapped,
the membrane is
electrically insulated.
And so the sodium ions--
or the sodium channels
and potassium channels,
the voltage gated ones,
localize to these nodes.
And when the action potential
is traveling along the axon,
because these regions
where the myelin sheath is
are electrically insulated,
the axon potential
doesn't just move continuously,
but jumps from node
to node, such that you are
just opening the sodium
channels at these nodes.
And that allows the
action potential
to travel about 100-fold
faster along the axon.
And that's what
allows your neurons
to transmit these
electrical signals
from the base of your spine
to your foot so rapidly.
So you get an increase in speed
because the action potential
is jumping from node to node.
And one important
reason to bring this up
is because there is an
important human disease that
affects the electrical
insulation in the myelin sheath
here, and that's
multiple sclerosis.
So we're going to unpack
multiple sclerosis in a couple
lectures.
This is an autoimmune disorder.
And so we're going to talk about
immunity later in the semester,
and we'll talk about
how that happens.
But for now, I just
want to point out
that multiple sclerosis happens
when the immune system attacks
this myelin sheath.
So in multiple sclerosis,
the myelin sheath is damaged.
And if you damage this
electrical insulation,
you greatly slow down
these action potentials,
and that has a
significant impact
on nerve impulses in the brain
and throughout the entire body.
And that's why
multiple sclerosis
is such a devastating disease.
All right, I'm going
to start moving now
to consider more
than one neuron.
So until now, we've
just talked about how
an electrical signal is sent
along the length of one cell.
And now we're going to start
thinking about multiple neurons
and how they connect and how
neurons integrate information
from multiple other neurons
to decide whether or not
to send an action potential.
And so if we consider this
connection right here,
there's a synapse right here.
Here's a cell that's
sending information
and a cell that is
receiving that information.
When we're considering
a synapse--
so if we consider
a synapse, there's
a cell that is sending
the signal, which
is called the presynapse.
This is the sender cell.
And there's a postsynaptic cell.
But you can have
more than one neuron
sending a signal to a neuron
at a given time, right?
So here, you have
one neuron that's
sending a signal
at this synapse,
but you might have another
neuron sending a signal
to a synapse on this
part of the cell.
And you could have another
signal coming in here.
And so this neuron
will then have
to decide whether or
not to fire an action
potential down its axon.
And the way that the
neuron decides this
is to integrate the signals.
So there's a signal
integration process.
And what's important for signal
integration in a neuron is
whether or not the cell body--
whether the voltage increases
above a certain threshold
potential.
So if the cell body
doesn't increase--
if the voltage doesn't
increase above this potential,
there will be no
action potential fired.
But if the voltage increases
above the threshold potential,
then it fires the
action potential
and signals to a
downstream neuron
or muscle or another cell.
So here, it is the threshold
potential in the cell body
that determines whether or
not an action potential is
sent down the axon.
And there are different
types of signals
that nerve cells can send.
So there are different
types of signals.
Signals can be excitatory,
meaning it will
tend to depolarize the neuron.
So there are excitatory signals,
which result in depolarization.
For example, with
serotonin, that
opens the sodium channel, and
that results in depolarization,
so that's an excitatory signal.
But there are other
types of signals
that bind to different types of
receptors that are inhibitory.
What might be a type
of receptor that
would inhibit this process of
sending an action potential?
What might an
inhibitory receptor
be to lower the chance that this
action potential will be fired?
What if I told you
it's an ion channel?
What ion would you
expect it might pass?
Udo?
AUDIENCE: Potassium.
ADAM MARTIN: Potassium.
Udo is exactly right, right?
If it passes
potassium, then it's
going to make the
inside more negative.
And that's what's known
as hyperpolarization.
So receptors that result
in hyperpolarization
would have an inhibitory
effect on this process.
And remember, if
you're hyperpolarizing,
then you could cause this
to actually go down and get
even farther away from this
threshold potential, right?
And if you have an
activating signal
and an inhibitory signal,
they might cancel out,
because one will depolarize and
the other will hyperpolarize.
So it's in this way a neuron
is able to integrate signals
coming from different neurons.
And that influences
whether or not
it will send the signal
to a downstream cell.
OK, so now we're
focusing on what
is the communication between
one neuron and another.
And this revolves
around this thing
that's called the synapse,
which is basically
the gap between the axon
terminal of one neuron
and the dendrites of
a postsynaptic neuron.
And so the way that
multiple neurons communicate
with each other are
through a type of signal
known as a neurotransmitter.
And this is what
initiates the signal.
So there's a signal initiation
process at the synapse.
Initiation.
And this involves the
presynaptic neuron
secreting a neurotransmitter.
So the signal, in this case,
signals between neurons
are called neurotransmitters.
And as you see on
the slide, these
are examples of
neurotransmitters.
They're often derived
from amino acids,
and so they're small molecules.
They're not the
proteins that you often
see with receptor
tyrosine kinase ligands.
This is a different
class of signal.
So one example is serotonin.
And if you look up at those,
we'll find serotonin here.
There it is.
Here, you can see it's a
derivative of tryptophan.
So it's a small
molecule, and it's
able to bind to a receptor
on the postsynaptic cell
and induce depolarization.
And so neurons are-- the
way that they communicate
is-- neurons are a case of
where luck favors the prepared.
Neurons are totally prepared
to send signals to each other.
They have everything ready
to go when they get word
from upstream, and they're
ready to send signals
to the next cell.
And that's because if
we look at the synapse
prior to an action potential,
everything is ready to go.
The cell has
neurotransmitter, and it's
packaged in these vesicles,
and it's tethered to the plasma
membrane, ready to be released.
So prior to the
action potential,
there are vesicles filled
with neurotransmitter that are
docked at the plasma membrane.
I abbreviate plasma
membrane PM, just so I
don't have to write it out, OK?
So these contain
neurotransmitter, right?
But you see in this
docked vesicle,
the neurotransmitter
is in red, and it
can't get out if
that vesicle does not
fuse with the plasma membrane.
So these contain
neurotransmitter.
But at this point, the
vesicles haven't fused.
But the vesicle's not fused.
When should they fuse?
In this system of neuron
signaling to each other,
when should the vesicle fuse
with the plasma membrane?
What should trigger
the fusion process?
Yes, Miles?
AUDIENCE: So after
[INAUDIBLE] axon
when it's time for
the [INAUDIBLE]
that's when the vesicles fuse.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah, so
Miles is exactly right.
If we consider my
diagram here, there's
an action potential
traveling along this axon.
When it gets to
the axon terminus,
that should be the
signal for these vesicles
to fuse to the plasma
membrane and to release
neurotransmitter.
So it's the arrival of the
action potential, right?
So remember, in
this case, serotonin
is going to be in blue.
If serotonin is inside
my vesicle here,
it's going to need to exocytose.
And now the serotonin is
going to be outside the cell,
ready to bind to the receptor.
All right, so as
Miles pointed out,
you have an action potential.
The fusion should be triggered
by the action potential.
In order to fuse,
there needs to be
some signal inside the cytoplasm
to tell the vesicles to fuse.
That signal is increased
calcium ion concentration.
And then when
calcium concentration
increases in the
cytoplasm, that triggers
the fusion of these vesicles.
And when you get fusion,
that's exocytosis,
and the serotonin is now
on the outside of the cell,
where it can travel across
the synaptic cleft and bind
to a receptor on the
postsynaptic neuron.
So this fusion is when
neurotransmitter is released.
Neurotransmitter
is released here.
And the way that this increasing
calcium has to happen,
when the action potential
arrives at the axon terminus.
So when it arrives
in the axon terminus,
there's depolarization
of that part of the cell.
And so there's a
special type of protein
called a voltage-gated
calcium channel.
All these channels are very
selective for different ions.
So a voltage-gated
sodium channel
isn't letting in all of
the ions outside the cell.
It's selective to sodium.
And this case, this
voltage-gated calcium channel
is just going to let in calcium.
And then there's a mechanism
that links calcium entry
to vesicle fusion.
And that's going
to be shown here.
What you see on this
docked synaptic vesicle
is this calcium-binding
protein called synaptotagmin
that's present on the vesicle.
And so when calcium
goes into the cytoplasm,
that protein binds to calcium,
and it activates the fusion
machinery such that the plasma
membrane of the vesicle fuses--
or the membrane of the vesicle
fuses with the plasma membrane
of the cell, thus releasing
the neurotransmitter
into the synaptic cleft.
So this is what
starts the signal.
Now, you probably know that
these neurons are not active
or on all the time.
So something has to
terminate the signal, usually
quite rapidly.
So now I want to
talk about that.
So like all signaling
pathways, signaling
is useless if you
can just turn it on.
You have to be able to
toggle it on and off in order
for biological systems to
function properly, right?
And that's the
case with neurons.
If you just turn
on a neuron and you
don't have a way to
turn it back off again,
then that's pretty useless.
And so we have to have a
way to turn off the signal.
And if we consider
the synapse, this
is the presynaptic neuron here.
I'm going to draw a
postsynaptic neuron here.
And neurotransmitter is released
by the presynaptic neuron
to the postsynaptic neuron here.
Neurotransmitter is released
into the synaptic cleft.
So the sort of
extracellular region
between these two neurons is
called the synaptic cleft.
So now the cell just
dumped a whole boatload
of neurotransmitter into
the synaptic cleft, right?
How is it going
to turn this off?
What does it have to do?
Yeah, Stephen?
AUDIENCE: It could absorb the--
take back in the [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM MARTIN: Stephen's
exactly right.
What Stephen
suggested is, is there
a way for the presynaptic
neuron to reabsorb
this neurotransmitter
and, thus, recycle it?
So it could either
reabsorb it or degrade
the neurotransmitter.
Different process for
different neurotransmitters.
For serotonin,
there are channels
that are present in
the plasma membrane,
and these mediate
reuptake of the serotonin.
So you have channels
that are basically--
after the neurotransmitter
is released,
it sucks the neurotransmitter
back into the presynaptic cell
such that it can then reuse
the neurotransmitter later on.
And so this process of reuptake
highlights a very important
process that's been
utilized by drug companies
to create antidepressants.
So antidepressants
like Prozac and Zoloft
affect this reuptake process.
And what that does is it
keeps the neurotransmitter
in the synaptic cleft
for longer, such
that it enhances the signaling.
And so the idea
behind these drugs
is that if you are
suffering depression
from a lack of
serotonin, then you
can rescue that by
preventing the rapid reuptake
of the neurotransmitter
into the cell
after the synapse is stimulated
and the neurotransmitter
is released.
And so Prozac, Zoloft,
these are a class
of drugs that are known as
selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors.
It's kind of a mouthful.
This is abbreviated SSRIs.
But the way they function is
to leave the neurotransmitter
in the synaptic
cleft for longer so
that you enhance
signaling, even if you
have low levels of the
neurotransmitter to begin with.
I also want to point out that
if we look at this diagram here,
the synaptic vesicle
fuses, and then this
releases the neurotransmitter.
But all the machinery
on this vesicle
is recycled by endocytosis such
that it can be reused again,
OK?
So cells are really
good at recycling stuff.
If this is sort of the membrane,
you endocytose and then
you can use it
again later on, OK?
And so there's recycling not
only of the neurotransmitter,
but also all of the machinery
on the synaptic vesicles
that are responsible
for the fusion event.
All right, now I want to
end by just telling you
how this experiment
works, where we're
able to activate specific
neurons in a brain
and that leads to the
animal sort of waking up.
So in a normal neuron--
so this is the last
part, optogenetics.
And I'm going to go
through this very fast.
But normally, you need
a neurotransmitter
to induce depolarization.
But what optogenetics
is, is an approach
to control the activity
of a cell with light, OK?
So in this case,
we're going to have
light inducing depolarization.
And the way this is done is
there's a protein discovered
from photosynthetic algae
that's responsive to light,
and it is a sodium channel.
And this protein is called
channelrhodopsin, specifically
ChR2.
And this is a light-sensitive
protein where light
induces sodium channel opening.
So that's going to
depolarize the cell.
And what you can do is if
you have a gene that you know
is specifically expressed
in a certain type of neuron,
you can take the promoter and
enhancer region of that gene
and hook it up to this single
component, channelrhodopsin,
that open reading frame, using
recombinant DNA technology.
And if that's expressed
specifically in the neurons
that you're trying
to test, you can then
shine a light into the brain
of the organism and activate,
specifically, this
type of neuron.
And that allows you to test
the function of the neuron
in the behavior of an organism.
So, in this case,
this mouse, the light
is shined into its
brain, and they're
testing a specific
type of neuron
that is involved in arousal
of the mouse, and it wakes up.
Oh, it's not playing.
So here, this is the
brain activity on the top,
and the muscle
activity on the bottom.
So you're going to see light.
There's the light.
You see it?
Light going into the brain.
They induce light at that
frequency for a while.
And then they're
going to wait and see
when the mouse wakes up.
And it's going to
wake up right now.
There it goes.
It woke up.
You see now its muscle
activity is going, OK?
So you can test the function
of specific nerve cells
using this approach,
and it's because you
have a light-sensitive
sodium channel.
So I'm done for today.
Have a great weekend.
I will see you on Monday.